standard zen pools Fitch sinon vous dis
forcément quelque chose ce sont des
agences de notation elles sont connues
pour évaluer les pays elles peuvent
également évaluer les collectivités qui
en font la demande c'est le cas de la
communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines confronté à la
difficulté d'emprunter et à des taux
prohibitifs et pour aller chercher des
fonds sur un autre marché que celui des
banques il fallait être noté pour
rassurer les investisseurs les deux
agents sont accordés un A+ assortis
surtout d'une perspective de stabilité
l'idée c'était vraiment de diversifier
nos sources de financement et donc
d'aller sur le marché obligataire pour
trouver d'autres sources de financement
à moindre coût l'emprunt bancaire on
voit bien comment il se présente c'est
facile on fait un contrat avec une
banque bon là c'est un peu plus
technique ça demande un arrangeur passer
par un arrangeur qui permettra de nous
faire un contrat en allant directement
chercher de l'argent sur le marché sans
passer par l'intermédiaire de la banque
une note de A+ c'est certes moins bien
que le triple A bien connu mais qui
s'explique par le niveau d'endettement
de l'agglomération depuis 30 ans si on a
un endettement c'est parce que on a
financé la plupart des équipements des
infrastructures de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines se faire noter
cela un coup 50.000 euros mais selon la
direction financière rapidement
amortissable pour un emprunt de 10
millions d'euros sur le marché
obligataire l'économie pourrait être de
l'ordre de 1 million et demi d'euros
d'ici la fin de l'année la communauté
d'agglomération a besoin d'emprunter 30
millions d'euros en France d'autres
grandes collectivités se sont déjà fait
noter dans Paris ou d'autres
collectivités de la région Île-de-France